so this uh thanks for being here this
morning and I'm going to be telling you
about sparsifying generalized linear
models feel free to stop me at any point
during the talk and ask for questions
otherwise I might just go too fast I
please stop me and just let me
know so to start I'm going to Define an
abstract concept which I'm going to call
sparsification
in a sparsification
problem the setup is that we have a
function f ofx which is the sum of
functions f1x plus f2x all the way up to
FM of X here x is an input in RN so n
dimensions and let's think of all these
functions as mapping RN to R uh it's
says R here but you can think of it as
like uh non- negative real numbers
basically and of the function some of M
functions and think of M as being much
larger than n so these functions might
have a lot of repetitions or a lot of
redundancy because the number of
functions is much larger than the
dimension that the input is
in because we have possible redundancy
between the functions it's very natural
to ask whether I can somehow reduce the
number of functions in my sum while
still preserving my sum up to a good
approximation to formalize this let's
define the following two
Notions we say that a function f Tilda
of x X Epsilon approximates the function
f ofx if for all X and RN the difference
of FX and F Tilda is a most Epsilon
times f ofx a different way that's a
different way of saying this that's
equivalent is that F til of X is a one
plus or minus Epsilon approximation of F
ofx at every
point to capture this notion that we're
really reducing the number of terms in
my sum we Define we say that F Tilda is
s sparse with respect to my original sum
F if there are coefficients C1 to CM at
least zero such that F Tilda is the sum
of CI time fi where C are constants here
so it's like a weighted sum of my
original inputs fi however the total
number of distinct the total number of
non-zero terms among C1 to cm is the
most s then we call it
sarse and a very successful outcome of
trying to solve a sparse ification
problem is that s is at most n / Epsilon
s time a poly logarithmic factor in N
it's it's like you should think of this
is like linear in n and then some
Epsilon dependence and then logarithmic
factors so this is a great
outcome one common instantiation of
spcification that's seen a lot of uh
that's seen a lot of use in recent years
is applying specification to Le Square
regression problems so in this setting
we have vectors A1 to a m and RN B1 to
BM and RN uh B1 to BM in R and we want
to find a vector X where AI dox is
approximately bi for all I in the lead
squares regression problem we can write
this as minimizing a trying to find an X
that minimizes ax minus b 2 Norm squared
where here a is the Matrix whose rows
are Ai and B is the vector whose entries
are bi so that's the that's exactly the
Le squares regression
problem to cast this in in the language
of the previous slide uh we have some
function capital F ofx which is the sum
of these functions F ofx so we want to
minimize capital F ofx which is the sum
of these squared
functions if we were to instantiate a
sparsification
on this problem in other words we're
going to find some diagonal matrix s
corresponding to some coefficient C
where this F Tilda now is a sum of less
of the terms and if we're able to
guarantee that F Tilda approximates F
like this then we're able to guarantee
that for our sparsified problem that the
function value error well that the error
between the original problem is off by
most Epsilon so if we instead okay so
consider this the following type of
strategy we start with capital F ofx we
somehow find a spar ofier F till the X
where s is much sparer now only s terms
of M terms and then we instead solve Le
squares regression on this sparsified
problem then we've obained a 1 plus
Epsilon approximate solution to the
original
problem while only solving a problem
with s terms instead of M terms and S
might be much less than M like s is you
know maybe n over Epsilon squ so that's
great like so overall we've given a way
to reduce a dense possibly dense problem
to a sparse problem um yeah
another common instantiation of this um
is in the setting of graphs so in a
graph specification instance you have
now a weighted graph
G and there's some edges e with possibly
some weights W and we want to find a new
graph with less edges a smaller Edge
that e Tilda and reting W Tilda that has
not too many edges and approximates the
original graph in some context
in the context of cut sparsifiers you
can think that I have a function f of
UV of X for every Edge UV and the
function is W UV the weight times
absolute value XU minus XV and in that
context a cut Spar ofier would be saying
that this weighted sum of these
fuvs um is approximately 1 plus or minus
Epsilon times wlda of f for all vectors
X and RN if you're more used to the
combinatorial notion of cut spar ofier
what that's saying is here x is now a 01
Vector instead of an a real Vector but
those are actually equivalent
Notions if you replace the function f
now with W * XU - xv^ 2 then you ask for
the same thing this is known as a
spectral Spar ofier basically what you
can think of this as is some kind of
least squares regression on a
graph I've so all these examples I've
given so far least squares regression
and both graph instances can actually be
cast as something called a generalized
linear model in this setting we have a
function fi ofx which is some function
fee of an inner product AI dox minus
bi maybe in like an optimization
language what you can think of this as
is Fe is some kind of loss function
which is not necessarily Square we have
ai dox minus bi so so like so now the
study we should consider is each of our
functions fi is some loss of AI dox
minus bi which is kind of the error from
the the what we're trying to
fit in in uh for sparsifying generalized
linear models which you can Define
completely analogously the following
results are known for what types of
sparsities you're able to achieve
depending on the function fee so in the
case of Le squares regression uh which
is the first case where the function Fe
is y^2 it's known how to achieve
sparsifiers of size n over Epsilon
squar when f is absolute value this
actually corresponds to the L1
normification you can get n log n and
for other values of P less than two
between zero one or between one and two
you can get n log n times some extra
factors over Epsilon
squ as you can see when p is less than
two uh the bound is basically n over
Epsilon squ times poly logarithmic
factors on the other hand when p is
greater than two the best verification
bound you can achieve is n to the p
over2 over Epsilon 2 up to logarithmic
factors notice that this is not near
linear in N so there's like like there's
a there's a transition at two like below
two you can achieve near linear and
above two you cannot the best possible
bound you can get is end to the p over
two
is something
known like can I take Epsilon to be
large like much larger than one or like
do if Epson is much larger than one
um I don't know too much the most I can
say is for L2 there's some ver there's
something called like a restricted
invertibility theorem which is saying
that like I can find a subset of the
rows such that on the span of where it's
defined the minimum singular value is
large and you can prove it with also
techniques similar to BSS but I don't
know of any analog and other Norms I
guess I'm just thinking about the last
line is analogous to
spanners yeah and whether there could be
hope of having like a result that gets
to nearly linear but has a much larger
era like spanners too much oh I see I
see so so the last what Rasmus is saying
is in the last case it corresponds like
in a graph to a spanner spanner somehow
kind of like L Infinity objective in a
graph and there you can get poly
logarithmic approximations I believe on
General matrices it's not possible in
the same construction that that shows
that this doesn't work should uh be
should work which is anyways the
construction for this lower bound is
just random vectors in product is about
one over root n so get I think the
dimension can be like going down to n
and then you get some approximation
factor which is like d to the P over2 or
something there is some tradeoff there
that you can go all the way down to
linear but you get some po approximation
yeah not po logarithmic as you were
asking think there a few more questions
there so very basic question so in this
in the case where bis are not zero like
you don't have homogeneous like geneity
here so do you get to like approximate
for any X in RN where this is like
inside some like ball or something oh oh
you're asking um if the bis are not
homogeneous what do you do uh there's a
quite simple reduction where you just
say
AI dox minus bi equals like a
i1 DOT X comma bi right so like the
point is I can just lift to n plus one
dimensions and okay so so kind of
anything so basically you can assume
homogeneous for free right yeah yeah
because I can just lift to n plus one
dimensions and just ask to specify
everything there and this is like a
general n plus one dimensional Vector so
like this is this is sum n plus one
dimensional vector and this is like also
so yeah bi being zero or not is not too
important in our setting
yeah so I guess uh a quick followup so
you're getting this guarantee for x
deterministically or are you getting for
like some some some x uh like fixed x
with high probability um the interesting
point here is that you can get it for
all x with high probability it's not
that every single X is fixed is correct
with high probability it's actually all
X and RN are correct yes nice and that's
important for a lot of applications it's
like for applications it is it is not
sufficient that each X holds with high
probability independently because like
then what can happen is like you have
some X and then like the value just
becomes zero or something and
then yeah like then the algorithms
applying this might get
confused was that a
question
do you know this s like do you know
which s should you choose or this is
just a theoretical that there exist some
s good um the question is what type of s
should we choose to get a spar ofier so
uh these are theoretical upper bounds
but I claim that you cannot hope to get
less than n in like in like any kind of
generality the reason is
because um like my original input has
inputs in end Dimensions right so like
if I spars we do less than end term then
there's going to be some direction that
I'm completely
missing um and then in that case I can
yeah then it just can't work you need to
kind of like I need that the AI vectors
in my functions are at least like
spanning RN or something so you can't
get under n okay so like this is
theoretical bounds not algorithmic
bounds right like they oh oh oh sorry oh
you're asking algorithmically uh you
basically all these all these results
are algorithmic okay yeah yeah up to log
factors at least yeah
just yeah on the formula you want to
swap the minus one in the bi behind
you wait it doesn't matter I guess if
you wanted to hold for an all AI where
like you have a single query and you
preserved everything for all you don't
want to be setting the bi in your xquery
vector based on the FI just want to set
to minus one and then get the guarantee
for
everything are you saying to oh oh you
saying to put the bi here yeah oh oh no
no aon's right aon's right aon's right
yeah aon's right yeah yeah so you wanted
to put you wanted to put the B here and
the minus one here yeah yeah sorry the
hand gesture was just to swap it that's
what you meant by
swap okay so this is basically like type
of verification known for like pee
Powers this is just these are basically
to all like tight up to log factors in a
lot of generality
okay as David was talking about
yesterday there are other classes of
functions which you can ask can you
sparsify so I think towards this I
there's two motivations I'm going to
talk about the first is just
understanding if I just have a sum of
different loss functions under what
conditions on the functions can I say
that they're spfi down to say near
linear size um and then I'll talk about
the second motivation later which is
some application to optimization so just
towards the first just let's just try to
understand what functions we can
sparsify so beyond LP Norms here's
following here's the following very
natural functions there's a function
called the Huber loss which for the
purposes of this talk you can think of
as just approximately the Min of the
absolute value
and the absolute value or like the value
squared uh this function is called the
Huber loss and to draw a picture the
function is locally quadratic but then
it eventually has linear Behavior and
the formal definition it's a version of
this that is differentiable everywhere
um like continuously differentiable
everywhere and such a function exists
it's called the hu loss and you can ask
and you spify that and more generally
you can Define these gamma P functions
which are the Min of the x of the P
power and X squ or P between zero and
two these results um uh mus musco
Woodruff and yasuda showed that you can
get sparity something like n^ the 1.17
over Epsilon squ by using techniques
that are quite specific to the structure
of these functions they're using that
that these functions do still look like
LP Norms kind of like their the men of
lpms so I can kind of use different
specification for lpms between one and
two to get some result for
this you can also look at this other
function called the two key loss which
I'm going to Define for now and this
function um is is locally quadratic but
then eventually it just becomes
completely flat and as mentioned
yesterday in David's talk you can get
something like n squar for this function
as a
sparsity however for these functions
it's not clear why these bounds are like
correct or whether you can do
better so for these functions basically
eventually I'm going to try to explain
why the these can be sparsified down to
linear size um is going to be what I'm
going to
say however not all functions that are
reasonably nice are spfi we can consider
the following function which is um as
written here it's like some kind of
symmetrized version of like a relu it's
like some threshold but symmetrized to
draw it one more time what this function
is is it's it's like zero for a while
and then it starts
contributing and you can ask if I have
the sum of fi of AI dox where the
functions look like this then is that
sparsified and the answer is actually no
um it requires exponential size and you
can show this via the following very
nice
construction let's we're going to try to
choose vectors A1 to a m on the sphere
in N minus one dimension so all absolute
value one such that the spherical caps
around them with dotproduct greater than
one the correlation
these are dis joint um the reason I can
pick exponentially many vectors like
this is because for any fixed Vector AI
the the surface area or like the the
volume of the number of points with the
dot product greater than 0.1 with it is
exponentially small so I can find a
bunch of different points where these
are all disjoint and then I claim that
you're not able to guarantee any
spcification in this instance the reason
is that well let's let's remember I have
fi is the sum fi of AI dox so I can
choose an X that lies in exactly one of
these caps one of these balls and does
not touch any of the
others and in that case well exactly one
function fi of X will have positive
value and the rest will all have zero
value because of the
definition so I can't afford to drop any
of the FIS because if I dropped it then
well there's a point where that's the
only coordinate that would have had any
positive value so I can't afford to drop
any points and spar requires exponential
size so I think the point of this
example was just to show that you know
well what what what's the difference
between these functions and just in
general what trying to understand build
more in more intuition for what kind of
functions in one dimension that we can
even hope to
sparsify sorry I got this a silly
questioni else zero zero near zero um so
the function is the max of zero and
absolute value y minus 0.1 so the point
is that I'm going to pick a a point x
around AI here so the dot product with
AI is going to be bigger than 0.1 the
dot product with anything anything other
than a is going to be less than 0.1 so
this quantity is goingon to be zero yeah
yeah and then the rest and then that one
thing is gon to be positive thanks sorry
yeah and this example is actually quite
flexible it shows that a lot of
different things are not spifi like
other things this example shows are not
spifi with you know slight different
versions of this construction are you
can imagine a function where if x is
negative it's like absolute value and if
it's positive it grows quadratically and
this example also shows that things like
this don't work with some small
changes
okay so that's one motivation for just
trying to understand sparsification it's
like what can we actually
sparsify um another motivation from the
optimization angle uh is algorithms for
LP Norm regression so recall like the lp
Norm regression problem is to minimize
ax minus B P Norm to the^ p and I'll let
P between be between one and two
okay recall the discussion on P equals 2
earlier which is Le squares which is I
have ax um and then what I had said is
that if I want to solve Le squares
regression you which is ax minus B2 Norm
squar I sparsify with s to find
something with difference about Epsilon
so I have a one plus or minus Epsilon
quality solution and the sparsity is at
most n Epsilon
s so naively this seems to suggest that
if I want a 1 plusus Epsilon approximate
solution to L2 Norm regression that the
runtime I would need depends on
something like Epsilon to the minus 2
you know I sparsify down to this many
rows n over Epsilon squ and I get a 1
plus minus Epsilon approximation so
that's kind of the naive
version I guess I would call this like a
low ACC algorithm because to make
Epsilon very small my running time goes
up polom in epsilon
right so it turns out that there's
actually like a million ways to do
better than this and I'm just going to
give one version of the argument um in
like my notation for these slides
because the generalizes a little better
to lpor
regression so instead of just arguing
that the sparsification gives a one plus
one plus or minus Epsilon approxim
solution solution as is let's consider
the following imagine that when we're
running an algorithm to solve this
problem we're at some point x0 and our
goal is to take a step Delta we're going
to go from x0 to x0 plus Delta to try to
decrease this uh L2 Norm error right so
let's compute how much I improve what
the difference is if I compute what the
difference is then this is exactly G do
Delta where G is the gradient of the L2
regression instance at x0
plus a * Delta to Norm s yeah once again
G is the gradient
right so now minimizing this left hand
side that's exactly solving the L2
regression problem so that's equivalent
to minimizing the right hand side right
now notice that if I was to minimize the
right hand side to a factor of two
approximation then I actually reduce my
function error like my distance from the
minimum error by 1/2 so it suffices to
minimize the right hand side to a factor
of two well now oh that's what I mean uh
what I mean minimizing the function eror
the difference between the original
error and xar went down by a factor of
1/2 when I moved by
Delta now we're actually in a great
space to apply sparsification we're just
going to sparsify a down to sa a Delta
except we're okay now with a factor two
approximation this is like Epsilon is a
half like a very large Epsilon
and now we can and now what suffices to
have the sparity to be o till the N with
no Epsilon dependence right um because
this procedure allows us to reduce the
error by 1 half then we just repeat this
log one over Epsilon times to get a 1
plus Epsilon approxim solution so we've
turned kind of a low accuracy algorithm
into a high accuracy algorithm by just
doing this instead of sparsifying just a
and arguing that way we take the
difference um and then we sparsify that
and argue that it helps us decrease our
function error by a constant factor and
we get a log one over Epson dependents
instead of a polinomial
Epson uh
yes
Function One You're
minimizing so so it seems the one thing
you did was to change the nature of the
function that you're minimizing a little
bit uh is it true that you know any say
good algorithm for minimizing a x minus
B that I might use off the shelf would
also apply to the function uh that you
have on the right hand side yeah exactly
oh good good good um it's like otherwise
I think that'll be an advantage of the
reduction that you first gave oh oh the
um the answer is basically that that
these end up being basically completely
equivalent problems the left hand side
and the right hand side even from the
point of view of say practice of you
know software packages I think Bas I
don't I don't know too much but
basically yeah oh okay I don't see a
difference I'm a little slow in
understanding this so you can you use
like a constant like to approximation
for this a * Delta versus S A Time Delta
why does this imply that you could get
also get this 1/2 like in comparison to
xstar oh good okay so if I was to
minimize the right hand side to if I was
to minimize the right hand side exactly
then what is the optimal value of the
right hand side it's exactly when Delta
is xar minus x0 right right yes okay so
if I was to minimize this to a factor to
approximation then I'm going halfway
towards the AL value which is half
in terms of function value exactly good
question so now you can instantiate this
exact thing for the lp Norm regression
problem and see what happens so here it
was very nice that I took I started with
an L2 instance I took the you know
second order expansion it was another L2
instance unfortunately the same thing
doesn't happen for LP normal regression
but you can still instantiate this and
see what happens um to just just to
write it out we have ax minus BP Norm to
the p and for notational in uh
cleanliness let's just write this as sum
fi AI dox minus bi where fi is the P
power okay we're going to do this for
General
functions and once again let's consider
starting from x0 and moving to x0 plus
Delta and Computing the difference right
if you compute the difference this
equals the following quantity um you
don't need to read it too carefully I'll
try to explain what's going on so the
difference is g. Delta where here once
again and G is the gradient and what is
the other term the other term is exactly
the bregman Divergence of the function
fi um this is just this is just by the
definition of bregman Divergence um the
bregman Divergence was is you know it's
the it's the FZ minus FY minus it's
basically how much further I'm above how
how convex I am when I move move to Z
okay so minimizing this quantity the
gradient plus the bregman Divergence is
completely equ equivalent to solving the
original
problem now let's let's think about what
the bregman Divergence of this P power
function is some calculations reveal
that the bregman Divergence of the P
power function is exactly this gamma P
function I defined earlier it's the Min
of something which is locally quadratic
and on large scales it looks more like
Delta to the
P so to minimize this quantity up to a
constant Factor we'll just replace every
Divergence with a gamma P function right
and now it's suffice to minimize this
quantity because we've only lost a
constant Factor so now we apply
sparsification to this thing uh if we're
able to apply sparsification to this
thing find some coefficient CI that
approximated up to a constant Factor
like just a two factor and see has s
spse now we've reduced our original
problem to solving something which is s
spse gradient plus some gamma P
functions so the point of this was that
if I want to solve LP regression where m
is bigger than N I can do do this
transformation I can sparsify the
Divergence part which is a gamma P
function and get a faster algorithm for
LP regression because they got sparer
yes yeah these function can be uh no the
bregman uh good question the question is
can these functions be negative the
bregman Divergence of any convex
function is positive by the definition
of convexity sorry uh where is it here
yeah the bre Divergence is a positive
function because f is
convex um that's the did that make
sense
um I thought that you know if gamma p is
your mirror map then minimizing the
gradient
plus the regman that Divergence is
precisely the mirror descend step
no I I don't have a good answer does
someone else have a good answer I don't
have a good answer sorry about that uh I
mean this particular useful
approximation to the bregman Divergence
that sort of makes it shows that it's
tractable is I guess from D paper and it
like
it's something you need to compute or
like like you need to verify that it has
a nice form I think in that language the
mirror map is a little more Dynamic
based on the iterate like I don't think
it's a it's a fixed function in quite
the same sense in that language but I'm
not 100% yeah this is not like a very
like like I wouldn't say that this is
like a
particularly like special framework it's
just a nice way
to like like the approximation is a
little more local versus a global map
like what what you described I think but
yeah yeah yeah yeah I guess here this
like thing is different depending on my
starting point in a mirror map it's
maybe more like glob it's the same this
is like yeah but in in this case it
doesn't really yeah in this case it
doesn't matter you just being able to
approximate the local like Divergence is
enough to get a but while I'm here one
clarification that that this decreases
by a constant does depend on some
geometry of the FI though oh correct
yeah yeah yeah the fact that a contactor
suffices depends a little bit on the
particular function gamma p
and than okay so um okay good so with
the so I guess piece okay yeah so um in
this uh I guess the point of this was
that if I'm able to give an algorithm to
sparsify gamma functions um then I'm
able to get a faster algorithm for LP
regression this is just another
motivation for understanding what types
of functions can I actually
sparsify so at this point I'm going to
get to our main result which is the
following theorem on sparsifying
generalized linear models so um under
the following conditions on the the
functions fi where here fi is a hi squar
okay sorry let me do it this way um so
suppose that functions H1 to hm satisfy
the following two properties the first
is that it satisfies some kind of
approximate triangle inequality thing
hiu minus HIV is the most hiu minus V
and the second is that the function hi
is growing a little bit like if I scale
up the input by Lambda then the function
value goes up a little
bit then if the functions fi are hi
squared so like another way to think of
it is square root fi satisfies these
conditions then I'm able to give a spar
ofier of uh the sparf fire of F that is
a valid sparf fire when the function
vales between Alpha and beta with the
following sparsity n Epson Square time
poly log factors time log beta over
Alpha so that's uh the main
theorem um the running time of this
algorithm to do this is basically
solving o Tia one linear systems like
it's this many leverage score
computations and this applies to the
following functions that I've described
it applies to all P powers or all
functions that are approximate these
gamma functions like Min of a square and
a p power and it works for powers
between zero and two and as a corollary
as discussed we get an algorithm for LP
regression that runs in that time n n Za
plus n to the Omega where Omega is the
current Matrix
how these are bounded below by some
Alpha couldn't make it zero
[Music]
um uh sorry like this is just our
specification theorem the specification
theorem is that like like that's our
theorem is that we guarantee
specification when the function Val is
between Alpha and beta um so I guess the
question is um I got so for all X such
that the function value yeah for all X
such that the function Val between Alpha
and beta we guarantee spcification it's
almost like you got tin oh that's one
way you can see it but like notice that
for things like the hu loss or these
gamma functions I can if I set Alpha to
be like sufficiently small like you know
like one over polym then I'm in a regime
where all the functions are homogeneous
already so it doesn't matter like then
then Alpha just goes to zero because I
said it to be small enough so um for
like reasonably well- behaved function
this is not actually very yeah um yeah
it's just for other functions that can
have that can kind of have wildly
different behavior and scales it's kind
of
necessary
so for the remainder of the talk um
there's I guess two goals we'll see how
far I get but the first goal is to try
to give some intuition for these
conditions and the second goal is going
to be to just describe very high level
how we sparsification algorithm looks
and how we uh go about
it so let's give some intuition for the
conditions so the first condition uh
these are the two conditions we had in
the algorithm as a COR are of the first
condition you can derive the following
two the first is that the functions
approximately symmetric this this is by
setting like V equals U equals z or
something um and another condition you
can derive is that the function U is
grow the function H must be sublinearly
growing h of Lambda U is most Lambda
time h of U and because F was h squ f is
growing sub
quadratically um sorry um so f is
growing sub quadratically as I said and
this is essential for sparsification
because um as I said if f is a p power
function and P is greater than two then
you cannot sparsify down to linear size
so that's like some intuition for like
where the first condition is kind of
useful it gives you some kind of
symmetry and it tells you some something
about sub quadratic
growth now the second condition is a
little more mysterious it's saying that
the function is like growing a little
bit it's like growing like Lambda to the
Delta for Lambda to the Theta for some
very small
Theta um so notice that this condition
actually prevents the our results from
being applied to this twoy loss which is
quadratic and then completely flat um
however the second condition like with
some tricks we can kind of get around it
in some specific instances so this Tross
is min of one and z^2 we can actually
show Spar location for this down to size
n to the 1 plus little low of one over
Epsilon squ um the idea is to just like
to smooth this function with Z to the
Delta z^ s and take Delta very small
these are good enough approximations and
now we've we've give we uh gotten a
function that satisfies condition two
and uh we can kind of do some stuff to
make this work I think the point is that
condition two is not too important but
it's useful for like technical points
what you really need is some kind of
more monotonicity and then condition
one I wanted to compare these conditions
a little bit to previous work of uh um
that studied M
estimators the first main difference is
that they replace the condition with
this sub additivity condition in h h of
V plus W and most that by taking uh W to
be uus V it actually is a little bit uh
stronger than our first condition this
isn't a big deal I think the proofs in
the other paper basically work under the
stronger condition another the more
interesting point that I do want to get
across is that in our results and no
place do we require that the functions
F1 to FM are all the same like it's it's
just completely not necessary um a
previous work does seem to use this
condition like in our theorem it it
actually the proof never sees the
functions F being related in any way
they just need to each individually
satisfy whatever hypothesis we want and
we can guarantee sparsification we don't
need that like they're all kind of the
same function like they're all you know
Huber or all 2 losses or
something good um at this point I'm
going to move a little bit into uh
actually maybe let me stop for questions
a little bit before going into like kind
of the last
segment any
questions
if not I'll continue a
little at this point I'm going to talk
about how you actually build sparsifiers
so I give you as input a function f ofx
which is the sum of these FIS of AI dox
and how do I actually build a sparf fire
like what's a general strategy to do
this the most General strategy
abstractly is this idea of important
sampling and I'll tell you a specific
instantiation of it so abstractly we
have a function f which is the sum of
functions
fi now an important sampling algorithm
for this is to Define different
probabilities Row one to row M that
probabilities who sum to one for these
functions fi to FM and we're going to do
the following procedure to build a spar
ofier we're going to sample s different
indices independently from row and
basically these s indices in 1 to M are
going to be the indices that form our
Spar
ofier the weights are going to be 1 / s
the number of samples times F of row I
divided by uh F of VI divided row of VI
this is what we're going to claim flda
is our spier so once again the procedure
is just Define a probability Vector
which I haven't explained how to do
sample s Times by this probability
Vector where s is about n and then just
take the weighted some so that it ends
up being
unbiased to see that it's
unbiased notice that the expectation of
FTA X is just the expectation of the
first term because there's s terms and
there's one/ s and the expectation of
the first term by the definition of our
procedure is exactly F ofx so the
procedure is in fact unbiased so the
more interesting part is to show that if
we take s samples where s is large
enough like n over Epsilon squ then in
fact it is true that for all F ofx where
the value is about Lambda that the error
is in epsilon Lambda if s is large
enough so this is what you would have to
prove about the important sampling
procedure to show that it's a sparf fire
that this errors
small the thing I haven't explained at
all yet is how you define these
probabilities Row one to row M so I'm
going to try to do that a little bit in
the next few slides I probably won't I
won't really get into the proof of how
you analyze this because that's quite
complicated but I'll yeah just you're
not saying fix Lambda
Max
um all F period no no no no um if you
want to show that f is a sparse fire it
suffice us to fix a Lambda and verify
this and then do it and then you know
check that is true for all
lambdas I guess your algorithm doesn't
depend on L the algorithm does not
depend on okay
yeah yeah well it holds true for the
algorith will like depend on Lambda kind
of but like yeah it holds true for any
fix Lambda you're saying this this in
equality holds true for any fixed Lambda
yeah that's right yeah but it holds like
yeah it holds any fixed L yeah but you
should imagine
um yeah yeah that's right
yeah establish it for all Lambda between
Alpha and beta right like yeah that's
right
yeah well establish it for all Lambda
between like the lower like the lower
function value and the upper function
value that we guarantee and
then yeah okay sure you might need a
union about over all lambdas but there's
like logarithmically many so you don't
really like you can like you you can
just imagine lambdas are powers of two
because they don't so then there's only
logarithmically so I'm just gonna now
I'm going to just going to try to
explain how you define the sampling
weights actually okay the main challenge
towards defining sampling weights for
these functions is that the functions
are non-homogeneous and that kind of
makes writing down the correct
definition of sampling weights to be
very
strange when f is homogeneous let's try
to draw a little bit of inspiration from
that instance there's a very nice object
called a leis weight which uh gives you
good sampling probabilities so here's
the following formula for a Lis weight a
leis weight w satisfies the following
equation wi equals the the right hand
side which is some kind of L2 like L2 uh
importance of the Matrix a reweighted by
these W so it's like a recursive formula
that uh gives you weights that are good
so this is the definition of Lewis
weights given Lewis weights for a matrix
a for an LP Norm we can do the following
sampling procedure we can Define uh row
I to be WI n and this is a valid
probability distribution because you can
show that the sum of the leis weights is
exactly n so the weight sum to n even
though there's M different
functions so it's known that sampling by
these row I gives a valid sparf when s
like the the sparity is about n over
Epsilon Square Times poly log
factors so in our setting where the
functions f are non-homogeneous what do
we do like how do we Define weights the
main idea is to actually fix a scale
Lambda that we care about so let's just
imagine as I was saying on the previous
slide we just care about trying to show
that function values F ofx that are
approximately Lambda are sparsified
correctly so X such as f ofx is between
Lambda over 2 and Lambda let's try to
show that those are specified
correctly um then at this scale Lambda
we're going to say that the vector D1 to
DM give a approximate weights if the
following formula is true uh fi of the
sare root of a transpose M inverse a
divided by di a trans M AI this is once
again an L2 importance of this Matrix M
basically and we want this to be
approximately Lambda for all I from 1 to
M and this is the definition of um D
like that's the definition of what we
call an approximate weight D okay given
an approximate approximate weight d our
sampling probability is going to be to
look at the L2 importance induced by m
so di AI transpose M inverse AI uh those
sum to n because they are L2 importances
we said row I to be that over n and
that's our sampling probability uh for
this scale
Lambda now we look at Lambda being all
powers of two where lambda's between
beta and Alpha over some polym and we
look at all these different scales of
which is logarithmically many and we
kind of take and we like do samples at
each scale according to these row eyes
and that's our overall sampling
algorithm you define dis the probability
the sampling probabilities at each level
and you just repeatedly sample at each
level and there's logarithmically many
so you increase the sparsity by a
logarithmic
Factor so that's the uh
algorithm yes yeah these are commutated
right these are transp are on either
side so these these are
just so these transposes are really just
implying that this is
commutated um the question is about the
transposes um so I guess there's two
things so on the right hand side di ai
ai transpose this this is like di times
a rank one Matrix and then the transpose
here is AI transpose a m AI that is a
scaler that's like an inner product with
respect to the Matrix a m basically
uh so while I'm not while I'm not going
to have a good chance to get into really
um what these weights are you can show
that these weights actually generalize
LP Lewis weights like for actually let
me do this let me do this calculation so
I claim that these actually exactly are
LP Lewis weights
um to see this let's just set Lambda
equals one
actually set Lambda equals 1 and fi of Z
is z to the
P right then in the numerator we're
going to have ai transpose M inverse AI
to the P over2 divided by di AI
transpose M inverse AI right and we want
this to be
one so if we cancel this out you get
di
equals this
quantity to the p/ 2 minus one and you
can actually show that if it's not too
long of calculation but if you let di
equal wi to the 1us 2 over P then this
exactly becomes the formula for LP leis
weights with a little bit
more think a couple more lines of
algebra
so this formula does exactly generalize
LP leis weights um and why I'm allowed
to set Lambda equals one there is
exactly because of homogenity it turns
out that if this function f is
homogeneous uh like it's a p power then
for all levels of scale the weights are
exactly the same up to
scaling let me just to wrap up I'm going
to try to explain why the weights
actually exist like I made a definition
I said we call these approximate weights
if they satisy this property I haven't
explained why these objects even exist
at all um to show they exist we we use a
idea from Coen and Pen which is we
Define some kind of contractive map and
this contractive map will show that the
weights
exist to set this
up let's start with some guess at an
approximate weight D and we're going to
define the following contractive map s
of D is going to be 1/ Lambda time fi of
basically the same formula we now MD is
this uh sum of diagonal matrix s of
D and notice that D is an approximate
weight is exactly equivalent to S of D
being approximately D that's the exact
definition of being an approximate
weight the idea of coant pen was to show
that this contractive map as as I've
defined they did it for Lewis weights
but in our setting the idea is to show
that this map SI is contractive in the
following sense that if D and D Prime
are gamma approximations coordinate wise
to each other then s of D and S of D
Prime are gamma to the C approximations
where C is a constant strictly less than
one given this we can get an approxim
weight in the following way we start
with just a weight d0 and let's say it's
a gamma approximation to S of d0 which
is um D1 right
now D1 uh Sor now D1 is gam
approximation now D2 is s of D1 is gamma
to the C approximation to D1 by using
the LMA once and applying the LMA T
times you deduce that D of t + one which
is s of DT is a gamma to the ca the T
approximation to DT by doing the
induction so now s of DT is gamma to the
C to the T approximation to DT and if
you take T to Infinity then well C to
the T goes to zero so this becomes
basically a constant like a one
approximation so this is just a short
proof that these weights actually exist
and you you show this with the
contractive map this proof is not too
long but I'm not going to do it
here so that's how you do the sampling I
just wanted to say like a few sentences
about how you actually do the proof I'm
not going to say too much so remember
that we want to show that the
expectation over FX the most Lambda of
this difference the most Epson Lambda
for all X
um under that remember that it's that
this is
unbiased uh so kind of the idea is that
you want to show by Union bounding over
all of X and RN that this quantity is
true uh RN has exponentially many points
so you can do a naive Union bound so the
idea is to as standard use chaining
methods to do this proof um and the
sampling weights the mysterious formula
I wrote down for the how you define
approximate weights was kind of exactly
to make a chaining proof
work and the chaining proof critically
uses this first condition that a hiu
minus hi is
hius one more point that I want to make
about making the chaining proof work is
that we need a little bit more about
these uh D vectors that's important so
we actually need that D of Lambda so let
D of Lambda be at scale Lambda what are
the approximate weights D our proof
requires that D Lambda and D Lambda over
2 are like within a constant factor of
each other basically this is essential
for a chaining proof and the way you can
actually check that this condition is
true is by using the contractive map
like the contractive map it says that
kind of every level has a fixed point so
the fixed points at adjacent levels also
end up being kind of close to each
other so yeah in summary we studied
verifying generally as linear models and
we sparsified it down to n over Epsilon
squ terms under some natural conditions
which I'm going to call Auto lipshits
and lower growth Auto lipshits it's the
hi difference condition and lower growth
is the um Lambda to the Theta
condition the way we did this is by
defining an approximate weight at every
level in scale and by doing important
sampling by those and to show the
weights exist we defined a contractive
algorithm based on ideas from
Co and uh to make the proof work we
employed chaining methods and it's
important that the weights of different
scales are related and we call this a
weight
scheme to wrap up I just wanted to say a
couple of future directions that might
be interesting the first is that um our
work mainly focuses on P less than two
so you can ask the following
generalization to P greater than two um
and I think the natural statement would
be if once again we start with this hiu
minus HIV and most hiu might just be
hypothesis but instead of letting hi be
the square root of Fi we're going to let
hi be fi to the one p and you're going
to say if fi satisfies that quantity
then can I guarantee specification down
to n to the p over2 over Epsilon Square
terms um and the reason our proof
currently doesn't work for let's say
large enough p is that our proof seems
to require this weight schemes like
weights approxim weights of different
levels being related and we don't know
how to show this for these exist for
large
P another natural direction would be we
studi these generalized linear models
which are one-dimensional functions fi
of AI dox
and you can ask whether if I make the
inputs a little higher dimensional what
I what I can say so instead now I have
FX is the sum of f of AI * X where AI is
a matrix let's say a d byn Matrix um in
our in our what I talked about today D
would be one but you can ask if D is
larger then what can you show um and
maybe I guess the first starting point
is what type of hypotheses would you
even need on these functions to be spfi
if they're homogeneous there's been some
work on that um but if they're not
homogeneous what do you even say and
maybe under under some the right
hypothesis can you get like a d times
nbound or maybe even an nbound I don't
really know of any natural lower
bounds um and another question is I
guess here we started studying
spcification for functions that were not
Norms or like not really homogeneous in
a good way so can you really get
sparsification for like other objectives
that are not really homogenous in a good
way like clustering objectives or things
like that I don't know too much about
this but I think it could be interesting
given that in this work we really
started studying specification for
functions that are not H at all so
that's all I had
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks so so this result like uh sort of
implies like for example like specifying
Square sum of Norm squares right
this result yes one I mean the one the
main result you showed like no it does
not because it's all one
dimensional uh sorry like the I thought
you are like these hi when P's one like
these are the capture Norms um and
you're looking at the square of them so
it's it's h i of AI
dox squ equals fi AI dox the whole
setting was with like inner products on
the inside
I oh I see okay the whole setting is
inter products on the inside yeah yeah
so this is what I was trying to get at
here is what if you don't have in
products on the inside you have like
possibly higher dimensional objects on
the other side oh I see okay okay
thanks can you make them
deterministic uh can you make these Al
the question is can you make these
algorithms deterministic um as far as I
know the only deterministic as far as
ification algorithm I know is when P
equals 2 and you do this BSS thing with
these like Trace potentials it would be
even very interesting to like just look
at L1 sparsification in The Matrix case
and ask can I get a deterministic
algorithm for
sparf uh I don't think I'm saying
anything wrong
here this is maybe like too vague to be
useful but do you have some intuition
behind why these importance weights are
always like at the core there's like an
L2 leverage score like why is it always
boiling back down to L2 um yeah why is
it always coming back to L2 uh I have a
couple different answers to that I guess
um I guess in a recent work again with
James Aaron and a run
we we showed that for LP Norm
sparsification you don't need to
actually use L2 defined weights to get a
sparf fire of near linear size you can
do something else like with LP so it's
like not clear it needs to come back to
L2 weights um
I guess when it comes back to L2 in this
setting it's often because you need some
kind of covering number bound and then
for that you like want to use this like
dual pacov inequality uh on like
covering um that would be what covering
an L2 ball with L Infinity balls with
like a few faces so you want to use that
so I guess that makes it natural to like
Define things that come back to L2
because you want to connect it
g
no more questions then let's uh thank
Yang
[Applause]
again now we have a break